hangouts Cobras my name is baubau
welcome to in real life so today we're
gonna do emojis I took a bunch of
beautiful pictures of myself we're gonna
mode you find myself
let's do Dias the first is the neutral
face emoji there we go there we go very
good yeah very good
[Music]
first off let's make this face circle a
baby
that looks pretty good you can't do not
that looks [ __ ] good
let's fix up theirs
beautiful beautiful results hundred
percent now let's add my face on top of
the face
[Music]
that looks pretty real doesn't it yes
100% realism that's what we do here on
the quota by channel let's finish out
with the mouth
[Music]
all right I don't know what happened
with the ice I don't know what the [ __ ]
this this is supposed to be but it's
there at ten out of ten would this is my
face but I don't get the booty next
emoji please face throwing a kiss emoji
there it is Wow
this face is going to that face how are
we don't shape change the shape of the
face and just go with that emoticon okay
let's do that
okay step one get rid of the nose like
giant ugly has potato nose
[Music]
oh my god yes
emoji pretty posh on Hawaii and now
let's side the heart about Sam going to
look at me as an emoji mm-hmm feel free
to use this face and you will get ladies
they will know what you're talking about
if you send this emoji
[Music]
fionna fault yes let's go to the next
emoji this is gonna be good one I'm
excited about this one I got three
pictures for this one we got this one
this one and this one and it's all gonna
come together baby my god my beard is
beardy and trim that [ __ ] first off the
ice we need to steal this I into there
there we go
second of all we need to merge another
eye on the other eye the [ __ ] am I
talking about oh my god hahahaha yes yes
my eyebrow go
[Music]
except a mouth
yep I'm scared John in Paris you scared
yourself said the tongue oh my god that
tongue is gonna be awful
[Music]
[Laughter]
this came out so good let's see when you
bring kill 8 to eject I worked so hard
for you bris how you repay me and I
don't want the world to see me cause I
don't think that they'd understand next
emoji the do I have something stuck in
my teeth emoji 100%
[Music]
now how do we make the ice so kawaai
well we're gonna have to find out what
if I can do that with my eyes I kind of
can okay I took it took a nice little
photo let's do the eye transplant oh my
god I love this technique it's so good
here's another awesome stock photo of me
I needed the bottom of my teeth
[Music]
big fan bins banned indeed baby yes
another successful emoji emoticon yes
okay let's finish off with nervous face
emoji my god that looks terrifying which
means we're doing it right
[Music]
[Laughter]
my face when I get the booty yes
beautiful you know to fall and magical
sorry okay let's see what your best
think finally at least make your eyes
circular I'm sorry I did well I'm glad
your breasts appreciated what I do for
you
leave a like I guess but you won't I did
I'll see you breasts in the next one I
had a lot of fun at least stay awesome
bros nice approach for our pick a pic
pic please
ain't no pic a [ __ ] without no piggy
tail oh my god that's good so this is
our rat tail looks like this is our
Pikachu scale look like what the [ __ ]